Silicon Valley may be a center of
innovation but some say what most needs
to change
is its own business culture a new book
claim Silicon Valley is rife with sexism
and the mistreatment of women both
workers and investors that culture and
what to do about it are explored in the
new book bro topia breaking up the boys
club of Silicon Valley we are joined by
the author of Bloomberg television
journalist Emily Chang Emily good
morning thank you thanks for having me
two years in the making what was the
most surprising thing you learned about
this future facing industry in Silicon
Valley you know the most surprising
thing to me was just how long bad
behavior has been not just tolerated but
normalized and so much of business in
Silicon Valley is happening outside the
office at the party at the bar the hotel
lobby sometimes in the hot tub I mean
you can think about it like Hollywood's
modern day casting couch and business
and social lives are increasingly
intertwined and that creates this really
great area where women are being put in
uncomfortable positions whether they're
an engineer at uber or they're an
entrepreneur raising money I was
actually surprised at the ratio of women
in the workplace there and how low it is
particularly I thought I thought for
example the financial world would be
worse but it's not even close Wall
Street 5050 at the top banks when it
comes to women and men women make up 25%
of jobs in the computing industry 7% of
investors women get two percent of
venture capital funding that is going in
to start this isn't the most progressive
industry in the world with some of the
smartest people in the world and even
when the women owned and run the
business they're still getting penalized
so the valley likes to say that the
issue is a pipeline problem is that
legitimate or is that cover I argue in
the book that the tech industry created
the pipeline problem by creating this
very narrow idea of who can do this job
and it goes all the way back to the 40s
and 50s when women were actually
programming computers for the military
and for NASA and then in the 60s and 70s
when the industry started to explode
they started doing these personality
tests to identify good programmers and
they decided that good programmers don't
like people
well they denied it yes the industry
decided
you look for people who don't like
people he'll hire far more men than
women and furthermore there is no
evidence to show the people who don't
like people are better at this job but
these tests became widely influential
and they were used for decades and it
has perpetuated this stereotype of the
antisocial mostly white male nerd that
many people imagine when they think
about computers and starting companies
like Facebook they're looking for people
who are casting avatars or these exactly
and think about all the people who don't
look like Mark Zuckerberg who could have
started the next Facebook I think about
all the women who didn't get a chance
and all of the companies that didn't get
a chance because they didn't look the
part you wrote about somebody who liked
to interview people in hot tubs you also
write about drug-fueled sex parties
being part of the culture here how does
that contribute to this you know the Bay
Area has long been a place where you
know people are exploring sexual freedom
and I've talked to both men and women
who are part of the scene there there
are sort of a wide spectrum of behavior
and in a lot of ways it's a lot less
about sex and a lot more about power and
the power dynamic is completely lopsided
you know the women in particular these
are women who are as I said are already
facing several challenges when it comes
to raising money if they go to these
parties they feel like they're
discredited they're not gonna get
funding if they don't go they feel like
they're missing out on an opportunity
because the people holding these parties
are incredibly powerful emily has a
Nietzsche movement come to Silicon
Valley the me2 movement in my view
actually started long before the me2
movement in Hollywood you we have an
investor here her name is Ellen Pao who
sued her venture capital firm in 2012
she lost in 2015 but she sort of won in
the court of public opinion and that
opened the door for more women to come
forward and it didn't happen right away
we saw a Susan Fowler the engineer at
uber who was propositioned for sex by
her manager on her first day on the job
and when she brought it to HR they said
we're gonna let that slide because he's
a high performer and subsequently many
more women have come forward it doesn't
get as much attention because it's not
you know Reese Witherspoon right or Rose
McGowan but it's happening to women in
Silicon Valley every day well it is an
incredibly well timed book Emily for the
moment in American reconciliation as it
were Emily Chang with growtopia thanks
so much